[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend die Stichwahl in der
Türkei ist vorbei und sie ist für alle
nicht Erdogan Wähler ein Stich ins Herz
also für all die die sich einen Wechsel
und Veränderung gewünscht hatten nachdem
ja vor zwei Wochen kein Kandidat die
erforderliche absolute Mehrheit erhalten
hatte waren heute erneut 64 Millionen
Wahlberechtigte aufgerufen sich zu
entscheiden und sie haben es getan
mehrheitlich für Präsident Erdogan nach
Auszählungen von mehr als 99 Prozent der
Stimmen kommt Erdogan laut der
staatlichen Nachrichtenagentur Anadolu
auf
52,14 Prozent Kilic da Rollo also der
Herausforderer auf
47,86%, die oppositionsagentur Anker
meldet ganz ähnliche Werte und jetzt
gerade meldet der Leiter der Wahlbehörde
tatsächlich das offizielle Endergebnis
und demnach ist ist Präsident Erdogan
wiedergewählt worden das Buhlen des
Herausforderers am rechten Rand in den
letzten Tagen hat seinem Sechser Bündnis
also nichts gebracht Erdogan der seit 20
Jahren an der Macht ist wird es weiter
bleiben Anna Feist über die historische
Stichwahl in der Türkei
wir lieben ihn wir lieben ihn sind
Erdogan da in einer liebeshymne an sich
selbst nachdem fast alle Stimmen
ausgezählt sind gegen 19 Uhr Ortszeit
steht für Erdogan das Ergebnis fest er
hat gewonnen darauf ein Treue Schuhe ans
Volk
wie wir euch seit 21 Jahren würde
erweisen werden wir das weiter tun und
werden euch dienen bis zum Tod
[Applaus]
dann
aufgeputschte Anhänger in Freudentaumel
der
macht wir werden wieder gewinnen ich
kann gerade meine Gefühle nicht
beschreiben
ich bin sehr glücklich
[Musik]
dabei ist ihr Sieg wohl knapper als
erwartet Erdogan kommt auf knapp über 50
Prozent Killer auf knapp unter 50%. doch
für den Präsidenten stand der Sieg lange
fest schon am Vormittag vor dem
Wahllokal gibt sich Erdogan im
feiertagsmodus verteilt wie sonst nur an
Festtagen üblich ist Lira scheine die
Wahlparty schon am Vortag direkt ins
Präsidialamt verlegt sein gegen Kandidat
Kemal College wie auch in der ersten
Runde umringt von Personenschützern
mutmaßlich mit Schuss sicherer Weste an
der Wahl ohne in Ankara zuversichtlich
ist sie nicht die Opposition denn
College darulou habe entscheidende
Fehler gemacht sagt Cengiz John da der
für die Pro kurdische Jessy PP ins
Parlament gewählt wurde
die kurdische Stimmen sind entscheidend
trotzdem hat er sich anderen zugewandt
um nationalistische Stimmen zu gewinnen
er hat den Kurden das Herz gebrochen
tatsächlich zeigen die Zahlen schon
jetzt das College der Rollo insbesondere
in den Kurden Gebiete leichte Verluste
hinnehmen musste während Erdogan sogar
an Stimmen dazu gewonnen hat Janis
jamber kennt Erdogan gut er
prognostiziert düstere Zeiten
er ist bereit mit dem Teufel Geschäfte
zu machen wenn er nur seine Macht
erhalten kann vor wenigen Minuten meldet
sich dann noch College der UNO zu Wort
sichtlich enttäuscht
[Applaus]
wir haben die unfairste Wahl der letzten
Jahre erlebt alle Staatsmittel wurden
nur für die Regierung ausgegeben und nur
für einen Mann mobilisiert
er werde trotzdem weiterkämpfen sagt der
Geschlagene noch dann verlässt er so
schnell wie möglich den Saal
2018 hat Präsident Erdogan ein
Präsidialsystem installiert seitdem
hatte er so viel Macht wie nie zuvor und
die kann er jetzt weiter ausbauen Jörg
Brase steht für uns am Präsidentenpalast
in Ankara wo Erdogan seine Rede in Kürze
halten will was hat denn jetzt den
Ausschlag für Erdogan gegeben
wir warten hier jetzt auf den Auftritt
des marl-siegers hier sind 10.000 davon
Fans aufmarschiert die jetzt auf ihn
warte ich denke was denn Ausschlag
gegeben hat wir haben uns ein Stück eben
gehört das war zu einem großen Teil eben
diese Medienmaschine die für Erdogan
gekämpft hat ihm alles möglich seine
Botschaften rüber zu bekommen die
Opposition hat das nicht geschafft und
mit diesem medienapparate ihm auch
gelungen seine Wähler noch mal zu
mobilisieren an die Wahl und zu gehen
und im Prinzip das Ergebnis des ersten
Wahlgangs noch mal zu wiederholen und
was sicherlich auch eine wichtige Rolle
gespielt hat ist dass die auslandswähler
auch wieder in überboten Mehrheit für
Receiver gestimmt haben
bei dieser Wahl tatsächlich um Inhalte
also es gab natürlich Themen die sehr
wichtig waren wie das Thema Flüchtlinge
zum Beispiel auf das Thema Wirtschaft
war ein wichtiges aber
Präsident erdogan hat es verstanden zum
Beispiel bei der Opposition
ihnen vorzuwerfen dass sie mit
Terroristen faktieren das hat doch viele
Wähler sehr stark beeindruckt und was
man auch sehen muss ist und das glaube
ich kann man hier auch ganz gut erkennen
diese Inhalte das ist die eine Sache das
andere ist die Person des Präsidenten
hier wird ein konsolenkult gemacht und
Receiver Teil Erdogan Inhalten viele für
in der Lage die Probleme des Landes die
hat teilweise auch gefahren worden hat
der Phrase war das live aus angraa kurz
bevor der wiedergewählte Präsident
gleich vor seine Anhänger und seine
Fenster vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzung
also fünf weitere Jahre Erdogan nichts
wird es mit einem politischen Wechsel
auf diesen hatte auch serapühler gehofft
aktuell sitzt sie für die CDU im
Bundestag zuvor war sie Staatssekretärin
für Integration in Nordrhein-Westfalen
und damit einen schönen guten Abend an
die türkische Schwarzmeerküste
guten Abend Frau Hayali Frau Güller wie
bewerten sie denn den Ausgang dieser
Wahl
viele haben sich etwas anderes gewünscht
zumindest 48 Prozent der Türkei und
allerdings muss man sagen dass seit dem
14 mai seit der ersten Runde dieses
Ergebnis heute Abend am Ende doch keine
große Überraschung ist überraschend ist
vielleicht doch das ist am Ende auch
wieder nur 52 Prozent für Erdogan sind
weil er hat sich ja tatsächlich mehr
erhofft und auch die AKP auch wenn Sie
gerade hinter mir ziemlich viel feiert
mit dem erneuten Sieg Erdogans ist ja so
muss man vielleicht formulieren auch
westliches Wunschdenken zerplatzt auch
das der CDU ihre Partei stand ja lange
an der konservativen Seite der AKP bis
Erdogans Partei ja dann immer
autoritärer wurde
das kann man sagen bis 2011 bis 2012 und
spätestens ab da auch wenn es vorher
schon Anzeichen dafür gab aber
spätestens ab 2012 und muss an einem
Datum mal fix zu machen kann man schon
sagen dass Ergon einen kursschwenk
gemacht hat und somit auch keine Rede
mehr von einer Partei politischen
Zusammenarbeit mit der CDU die eine Rede
sein kann tatsächlich aber bleiben wir
noch mal bei diesem zerplatzen des
Wunschdenkens da waren ja im Vorfeld
Prognosen eindeutig eher in Richtung des
Herausforderers jetzt sind die Wahlen
anders ausgegangen in Deutschland
insbesondere auch in Nordrhein-Westfalen
wo sie ja Staatssekretärin für
Integration waren steht auch eine
Mehrheit der Wahlberechtigten hinter dem
Präsidenten und alle anderen Fragen sich
so ein bisschen wie kann man hier leben
in einer liberalen Demokratie und dann
Erdogan wählen als Antwort folgt dann
oft gut die sind nicht integriert ist es
wirklich so einfach
nein so einfach ist es definitiv nicht
das ist auch ein sehr hartes
Pauschalurteil sind auch viele
Akademikerinnen und Akademiker in
Deutschland beispielsweise die sich für
algoron entschieden haben sind ganz
unterschiedliche Gründe ein Thema was
immer wieder genannt wird ist dass die
also das Deutschland die
Integrationspolitik dieser Menschen oder
für diese Menschen verschlafen hat ist
sicherlich ein Grund aber ich glaube der
wichtigste Grund ist tatsächlich das ist
Erdogan schafft ein Vakuum zu füllen und
diesen Menschen das Gefühl gibt der
Anerkennung aber eben auch Ihnen das
Gefühl gibt er ist der starke Mann für
die Türkei und dank ihm ist die Türkei
wieder wer und darauf legen ganz ganz
viele Menschen die sich in Deutschland
für Erdogan entschieden haben auch eben
Wert also Menschenrechte Umgang mit
Kritikern Wirtschaftslage spielen keine
ganz so große Rolle ist denn dann das
Unverständnis was man den Erdogan
Anhängern entgegenbringt würden Sie
sagen ein Fehler bzw führt das zu
Mobilisierung hier wie auch in der
Türkei
es gibt da verschiedene Ansätze
verschiedene Theorien einige sagen jetzt
erst recht wenn ihr andauernd meint so
ein Erdogan Bashing in den deutschen
Medien oder als deutsche Politiker
betreiben zu müssen dann wähle ich ihn
erst recht aber ich glaube noch mal das
sind ganz unterschiedliche Gefühle und
das Gefühl dass die Türkei es zu einer
bestimmten Stärke dank Erdogan gebracht
hat zählt bei ganz vielen Menschen dann
darf man nicht vergessen gerade was das
Ruhrgebiet an betrifft das sind ganz
viele Familien die aus Anatolien als
Gastarbeiter oder deren Nachfahren jetzt
die in Deutschland leben im Ruhrgebiet
leben wo die Eltern Großeltern als
Gastarbeiter aus Anatolien gekommen sind
und wenn man sich die türkische
Wahlkarte anschaut dann hat Erdogan ja
hier auch bei der ersten Wahl in diesen
Gebieten hoch abgeschnitten Mann ist da
natürlich im Austausch mit der Familie
und der spielen eben nationalistische
Werte wie dass es einen starken Mann
gibt der sich auch gegen den Terror
einsetzt eine größere Rolle als
menschenre Klasse Freiheit das muss man
leider so sagen und jetzt dürfen wir
auch nicht vergessen das Erdogan das
wurde ja in ihrem Vorabbericht auch
schon genannt diesen Wahlkampf stark auf
Terror gesetzt hat also Wirtschaft
versus Sicherheit und die meisten
Menschen gesagt haben ja die
wirtschaftliche Lage ist nicht gut aber
die Sicherheit dieses Landes ist mir
wichtiger und ich möchte keinen
Präsidenten der auf der Seite der PKK
steht weil Erdogan genau so diffamiert
hat also halten wir fest eine Mehrheit
der Türken wählt islamisch konservativ
nationalistisch trotz der schlechten
Wirtschaftslage autokratischen Zügen
oder aber auch dem wegsperren von
Andersdenken wohin das führen wird
werden wir dann in Zukunft sehen sehr
abkühler vielen herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Zeit ehemalige Integration
Staatssekretärin in Nordrhein-Westfalen
danke Ihnen
und die Wahlbeteiligung bei der
Stichwahl war im Vergleich zur Wahl vor
zwei Wochen mit knapp 85% etwas geringer
weitere Informationen finden Sie auch
zur Türkei weil natürlich jederzeit
online unter heute punkt de und jetzt
blicken wir in die Ukraine und da Hannah
gehen die russischen Angriffe im Grunde
nonstop weiter ja laut ukrainischen
Angaben hat Russland in der Nacht den
bisher schwersten Drohnenangriff seit
Kriegsbeginn auf Kiew geflogen aber sei
mindestens ein Mensch durch
herabfallende Trümmerteile getötet
worden und mehrere Gebäude wurden
beschädigt die ukraineische Luft war
versprach von einer Rekordzahl von 54
Drohnen landesweit 52 davon habe man
abfangen können
in Spanien waren heute bei den
regionalen Kommunalwahlen etwa 36,6
Millionen Menschen zum Urnengang
aufgerufen die Abstimmung gilt als
Stimmungstest für die Linke
Minderheitsregierung von
Ministerpräsident Sanchez vor der
Parlamentswahl Ende des Jahres seine
Sozialdemokratische Partei PSOE regiert
bislang in zehn der zwölf Regionen in
denen abgestimmt wurde der Wahlkampf war
von Debatten um die Wirtschafts- und
Sozialpolitik der Zentralregierung
bestimmt worden
wegen des Fachkräftemangels in
Deutschland hat unionsfraktionsvize
Spahn gefordert die abschlagsfreie Rente
für langjährige Versicherte die Rente
mit 63 abzuschaffen die zwei Millionen
Fachkräfte die früher in Rente gegangen
sein fehlten der deutschen Wirtschaft
bitterlich sagte Spahn gegenüber der
Bild am Sonntag als Ersatz schlug er
eine bessere Erwerbsminderungsrente vor
bei SPD Grünen und den linken stieß die
Forderungen auf Widerspruch
in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist nur drei
Wochen nach der Sprengung der Talbrücke
ramede eine weitere marode
Autobahnbrücke an der A45 zu Fall
gebracht worden am Vormittag brach eine
Fahrbahn der
sterbetalbrücke bei Hagen planmäßig in
sich zusammen der Verkehr wird nun
komplett über die andere Hälfte geführt
bis die neue Brücke fertig ist
die USA stehen vor einer staatsbreite es
droht die Zahlungsunfähigkeit alle paar
Jahre ploppt diese Nachricht auf die
nicht nur bei den Finanzmärkten für
massive Unruhe und Nervosität sorgt denn
die Folgen wären kaum absehbar die
Lösung und so wurde es seit Einführung
der Schuldenobergrenze im Jahr 1917
schon mehr als 100 mal gehandhabt ist
ganz einfach man erhöht die Schulden
Obergrenze nicht so einfach ist der Weg
dahin denn die Opposition versucht den
Präsidenten zuvor einiges abzuringen und
zwar Zugeständnisse bzw
Ausgabenkürzungen so war es auch dieses
Mal Elma teven über den Deal den beide
kann man allerdings das Kongresses noch
zustimmen müssen
damit es nicht zappenduster wird für die
US-Wirtschaft kam aus dem Kapitol letzte
Nacht die frohe Botschaft ich habe
gerade mit dem Präsidenten telefoniert
nach wochenlangen Gesprächen haben wir
jetzt eine Vereinbarung zumindest im
Prinzip
die USA können demnach weiter Schulden
machen die Obergrenze wird für die
nächsten zwei Jahre erhöht allerdings
dürfen die Ausgaben 2024 trotz Inflation
nicht steigen im Folgejahr nur maximal 1
%. eine Reihe von Programmen wird dafür
gekürzt nur der Militärhaushalt ist
ausgenommen insgesamt würde der Staat
650 Billionen Dollar über 10 Jahre
weniger ausgeben beide Seiten mussten
wie man so sagt Kröten schlucken
Sozialprogramme die die Republikaner
kürzen wollten bleiben weitgehend
unangetastet dafür verzichtet beiden auf
weitere Steuererhöhungen für Reiche und
muss auch zulassen dass Auflagen für die
Verteilung von Lebensmittelmarken an
ärmere verschärft werden noch
feilen die die Maker am Kleingedruckten
aber beide rechnen fest mit Zustimmung
ich werde mir Kaffee jetzt gleich noch
mal anrufen um sicherzustellen dass
alles wirklich passt
wir sind dadurch der erste Kongress der
für eine Senkung der Ausgaben stimmt für
mehrere Jahre
am Mittwoch könnten sie den Deal hier
noch platzen lassen der linke Flügel der
Demokraten will nur zustimmen wenn
besonders Hilfsbedürftige bei den
Auflagen für Lebensmittelmarken
ausgenommen werden
es ist wirklich unglücklich dass der
Präsident das zulässt vielleicht ist es
durch die Ausnahme noch akzeptabel aber
das will ich noch nicht versprechen
bei den Republikanern könnte es wie bei
der Wahl von McCafe im Januar Tumulte
geben denn die radikalen in der Fraktion
signalisieren jetzt schon knallharte
ablehnen fast nichts hat mcafe erreicht
twittert einer ein anderer nennt es
schlicht Kapitulation aber ein mcafé
getreuer signalisiert die Kritiker
brauche man nicht für eine Mehrheit
ehrlich gesagt die würden nicht
zustimmen selbst wenn Mutter Teresa
aufersteht und sie bittet und trotzdem
wird das Ganze durchgehen
darauf hofft auch die Börse denn wenn es
schief geht während selbst
US-Staatsanleihen nicht mehr sicher die
Märkte könnten stürzen um das zu
verhindern Liebe dem Finanzministerium
noch ein verrückt klingender Schachzug
es könnte eine Platin Münze von One
trailian Dollars prägen und dann
Kollegen als Sicherheit für weitere
Schulden
und es sind natürlich nicht 650
Billionen Dollar sondern Milliarden aber
bei denen zum kann man auch schon mal
leicht durcheinander kommen und jetzt
kommen wir zum Sport und da gab es in
München Hanna doppelten Grund nicht zum
Feuern das war gestern sondern zum
Feiern ja nach den Männern gestern haben
heute nämlich auch die Fußballfrauen des
FC Bayern München den Meistertitel
geholt nach einem fulminanten 11:1 gegen
Absteiger Potsdam auf dem Münchner
Marienplatz wurden die beiden Teams am
Abend von tausenden Fans bejubelt für
die Fußballerinnen ist es der fünfte
Meistertitel die Männer haben die Schale
zum 33 mal in die bayerische
Landeshauptstadt geholt
überschattet wurde der doppelte Meister
Jubel allerdings durch die Trennung der
Bayern von Vorstandschef Kahn und
Sportvorstand Sally hamidžić
Clubpräsident Heiner stellte heute
mittags Nachfolger vor den ehemaligen
Finanzvorstand des FC Bayern Jan
Christian
Abwesenheit beim gestrigen Spiel in Köln
begründete Heiner damit dass die
Trennung nicht einvernehmlich gewesen
sei kam selbst wieder sprach bei Twitter
es sei ein ruhiges und sachliches
Gespräch gewesen
gemacht haben und seit heute steht fest
der erste fC Heidenheim steigt in die
erste Bundesliga auf das ist eine
Premiere in der Vereinsgeschichte die
Fans feierten das entscheidende Tor zum
3:2 gegen Regensburg in der 9 Minute der
Nachspielzeit Heidenheim ist damit
Zweitliga Meister für die Anhänger des
Hamburger SV heißt es dagegen weiter
zittern der HSV muss in die Relegation
gegen den VfB Stuttgart
[Applaus]
Vorrunde überlebt bärenstarke Schweizer
geschlagen die Eishockey Nation USA
geschlagen und heute im Finale gegen
Kanada sehr lange auf Augenhöhe
mitgespielt wenn man also von einem
Märchen in Bezug auf die deutsche
Eishockey Nationalmannschaft spricht
dann ist das schon zutreffend wenn auch
Märchen ohne Happy End denn wie schon im
Finale 1930 der Gegner damals übrigens
hieß auch Kanada und da lag das deutsche
Team dem Rekordweltmeister Andreas Heck
eindeutige Ausgangslage Kanada 27 Mal
Weltmeister Deutschland noch nie doch
die Außenseite zu Beginn Spiel bestimmt
John Jason patakar nach passt von Moritz
Seider 1:0 in der achten Minute kann er
das Antwort folgt umgehen nur zwei
Minuten später der Ausgleich durch
Samuel play
im zweiten Drittel Vorteile für Kanada
aber Maximilian Kastner bringt den Puck
zu Daniel fischbruch und er bringt sein
Team wieder in Führung dann die
disziplinierten deutschen zum ersten Mal
in Unterzahl Kanada nutzt sein Powerplay
2:2 der Rekordweltmeister erhöht im
letzten Drittel den Druck Samuel play
mit seinem zweiten Treffer zur ersten
Führung Kanadas im Angriff vertempelt
dann Marcel nübels den Puck die Chance
zum 4:2 nutzt mit einem solokapitän
Teile TV
Bundestrainer Harald Kreis nimmt schon 3
Minuten vor dem Ende Goalie Niederberger
vom Feld Kanada trifft ins leere Tor zum
5 zu zweit
die deutschen verlieren das Finale in
Tampere durch Willenskraft und Teamgeist
gewinnen sie aber Silber die erste
WM-Medaille seit 70 Jahren
und jetzt der Blick auf die ziemlich
freundlichen Wetteraussichten am
Pfingsten Montag ist der Himmel in der
Mitte und an den alten zwar zeitweise
bewölkt sonst scheint aber trotz
Schleierwolken die Sonne dabei werden 20
bis 27 Grad erreicht im Norden und
Nordwesten 14 bis 20 Grad am Dienstag
gibt es bei 14 bis 25 Grad mehr wollten
aber es bleibt trocken ab Mittwoch
scheint die Sonne nur an den Alpen gibt
es ein kleines schauerrisiko jeden Tag
wird es etwas wärmer
ist doch ganz schön oder also bei diesen
Aussichten genießen Sie den
Pfingstmontag und die nächsten
Nachrichten gibt es hier gegen 0.20 mit
Anfang kuschelden machen sie es gut wo
auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]